de la Policía Nacional
en la ciudad capital y en algunos
lugares focalizados donde las protestas
violentas
han ocurrido el día de ayer
y hoy 19 de enero
también
mi agradecimiento
a los señores servidores de la Fiscalía
de la nación quienes al lado de nuestra
policía han actuado en ese servicio y en
ese respaldo al gobierno y al Estado de
derecho
también en esa misma línea mi
agradecimiento a los funcionarios de la
defensoría del pueblo
y a ustedes la prensa que hoy
de manera
permanente
han informado y han visualizado a través
de sus cámaras
todo el movimiento de estas marchas de
protesta cargadas en algunos puntos de
violencia
también quiero solidarizarme con
aquellos hombres y mujeres de prensa que
hoy han sido agredidos eso no es una
marcha de protesta pacífica
los actos de violencia generados a lo
largo de estos días de diciembre y ahora
en enero
no quedarán impunes el gobierno
actuará dentro del marco de la
Constitución y las leyes que ampara de
manera estricta y firme nuestra
dirección Nacional de inteligencia está
actuando con la firmeza que corresponde
y prontamente
estaremos junto con la fiscalía
verificando y abriendo las carpetas
Fiscales de aquellas personas que estén
generando actos de violencia
destrozos de la propiedad privada y del
estado
Asimismo quiero comunicar que hoy día de
manera concatenada a la misma hora
preparada con anticipación porque esto
no es una mera casualidad
han querido tomar tres aeropuertos al
interior del país
situación
que ya por el informe que tenemos
esto ha sido preparado con premeditación
con suma anticipación y reitero todo el
rigor de la ley caerá sobre aquellas
personas que están cometiendo estos
actos delincuenciales de vandalismo que
no lo vamos a permitir
nuevamente
al pueblo peruano
a las hermanas y hermanos que sí quieren
trabajar en paz que sí quieren llevar el
ingreso a sus hogares para sostener sus
familias a ella les digo y también a los
que están generando estos actos de
protesta a los que se han trasladado de
las provincias a la capital
no me voy a cansar de llamarlos al buen
diálogo no me voy a cansar de decirles
trabajemos en la mirada que el país
necesita la solución de agua
Salud Educación el tema de la
agricultura
el tema de cuidar a los alpacos la zona
ganadera más puentes más carreteras que
nuestros niños empiecen en marzo con
internet
a los que están marchando diariamente
quién los financia
porque no están trabajando y qué dinero
están llevando a sus hogares
Por qué están abandonando sus familias
para salir a la calle a protestar y en
sus protestas No hay ninguna agenda
social que el país necesita
en sus protestas son cosas que ustedes
saben
están al margen de la ley
ustedes quieren quebrar el estado de
derecho
ustedes quieren
generar caos y desorden y para dentro de
ese caos y desorden tomar el poder de la
nación
están equivocados
desde el gobierno
le decimos al pueblo peruano la
situación está controlada y estará
controlada porque sabemos que estos
señores no van a Cesar en su en su
propósito de quebrar el estado de
derecho pero también les decimos que
actuaremos con todo el peso de la ley
ya estaremos y estamos
individualizando a estos malos
ciudadanos que están generando actos de
violencia
aprovecho también
señoras y señores
hermanas y hermanos
que queremos vivir en paz en orden y en
calma para desmentir las noticias falsas
que han estado invadiendo todas las
redes el gobierno está firme y su
gabinete más Unido que nunca nuevamente
llamo al diálogo
llamo a la calma
aquellos líderes políticos
que están llamando a estas marchas de
protesta
tengan una mirada de país más sincera
más objetiva
más hermanada
y conversemos y dialoguemos
para traer la calma la paz la unidad y
el desarrollo de la patria Muchas
gracias y buenas noches